sie sehen sich voll ähnlich wir haben
jetzt eigentlich auch gar nicht gesagt
ob wir das stimmt wirklich geschwister
so dass ich nicht mehr raus hauen oder
somit nicht machen genau das jetzt auch
drei eigentlich sagen okay okay 123
[Musik]
etwas gedacht und herzlich willkommen
bayern will video ich habe heute nach
wirklich sehr langer zeit war wieder ein
gast im video weiß ich ob meine letzten
100 videos waren einfach alleine recht
besser ist eigentlich keiner mehr was
machen richtig spaß
ja wir haben uns mal getroffen um ein
video zu drehen kurz vorweg wir haben
rat schon einen mcdonald spring
aufgenommen der war wirklich krass das
ist was passiert der kommt am mittwoch
an länge mit 25 26 26 auf level 1
scheint vorüber
dadurch wird kreis nur solche
informationen gemacht an die ich kenne
das ist felix vom kanal flechsig ich
dachte bis eben noch er heißt auch alex
möchte er hat mich wirklich allerdings
grenzen ich habe mich auch so bei
baywatch ab eigentlich bei hat weil wir
uns kennengelernt in köln letztens und
mw dachte ich du weißt alles nötig weiß
felix das hat sich wahrscheinlich für
mich so angeht wie alex meier oder das
so schnell gesagt hast
ich habe schon ein teil ist er ist alex
ja was sag ich nur hier auch rechtliche
grundlagen wie dieses video machen ich
habe in meinen kommentaren schon sehr
oft gelesen ob man kann nicht ihm gehört
oder ob er ist mein bruder ist oder
irgend so und bei ihm steht das auch und
wir haben uns jetzt einfach mal jeder
von seinem kanal kommentaren rausgesucht
wie sie also man kann das ja so filtern
er hat sich manchmal aller kriege
filtern ich nach flexit das heißt ja
nicht wechselt also haben das halt beide
gemacht ich würde sagen wir lesen uns
immer gegenseitig bei diesen echt lustig
leute denken halt also manche leute sind
wird und verwechseln uns anscheinend und
deswegen machen wie sie ihr könnt ja
meine kommentare darauf die ähnlichkeit
wirklich so was habe dieses schöne
kapital ich habe so viele kommentare
also leute unvorstellbar ich weiß nicht
ich kann man also sehe ich will das denn
er sieht man leider nicht lässt machen
wir einen frame mit alex wie weil sie
euch jetzt ziemlich ähnlich aus
zwillingspaar oder so wäre mega lustig
das lustige ist genau das haben wir eben
gemacht und in mex mcdonald's gefahren
mit dann haben uns genau das gleiche
angezogen und die haben sich die checks
oder die habe ich auch kein folge steckt
ja aber jetzt möchte ich einmal kurz
einmal mit dem beschweren ich wollte
schon das dritte mal jetzt ja und ich
bin das dritte mal jetzt hier was steckt
nicht alltägliche aufgabe ja sagst du
jetzt gleich das du und dann richtig
bekannter ins land service ja ganz viele
war und dass du gleich erstmal einblicke
ins tor hinweg ist wie bei spannt
mittwoch unbedingt einschalten erstmal
ein lockerer kommentar so das ist so
kommentierte stehen so einfach so
schimpft bist du flexit weste dasteht so
unternahm unter meinem video darunter
alex wie die flags ist das alles oder
weiß es nicht ich weiß nicht vielleicht
vielleicht bevor wir uns einfach alle
bisher so langen nase herumgeführt und
wir haben einfach ein doppelleben die
ganze woche hast du gemacht oder kanal
von alex yoder ist das dein kanalisiert
auch ähnlich damit das war vor drei
monaten
der dort grüßt hausangestellte klartext
wie dann kann ich jetzt vollgas los
schon andere aber sind schlimm oder ob
das praktisch seine zweite kann darin
auch genau ich verstehe es ja wenn man
so ähnlichkeit hat so aber wie man
unseren kommentar schreiben kann also
manchmal wenn man jetzt von videos
dann erkennen wir noch ein unterschied
oder auch von der stimme ja das habe ich
beim mac auch nicht gezeigt die haben
auch von der stimme her über uvex merkt
gar nicht die sache ist keine ahnung hat
das sind ist es halt irgendwie so 59
leid ich war wechselte dich immer mit
flexit heute schreiben wir das ist halt
sein kommentaren kann man ja dann
nachvollziehen du weißt du der ist nicht
so dumm wie bist du flexit der scheibe
methode die kommentare hier will die eu
hier wo wir uns jährlich von den
gesichtszügen teil das würde auch sagen
werden gerade die mütter auch so das sah
schon wisst ihr denn ich bin das ist ich
kann ja mal was ich mal kurz direkt mit
dem weiteren ja machen weil ich ja passt
so der sammler aktive das ist doch dein
zweikanal fleck sind oder sich der songs
wie do co ersticht er spricht so in dem
kommentar so direkt dichter und gar
nicht so heftig dass nicht da steht ja
der name und da von mir anschaute
schreibt das ist doch dein zweiter kanal
alex wie der flex it heißt oder sieht
weiß ich weiß aber ich hätte da nichts
gegen schenkte mir einen kanal mit 1.000
abonnenten was das ganze soll bieten
finanziell so jetzt hab ich was richtig
gutes
er heißt es der typo3 ist bin ich der
einst sogar ein zweifelt ob er mein
einziger der manchmal alex wie flex
nicht unterscheiden kann auch sein vize
nicht immer sah nichts bleibt wie es
vielleicht kommen
gute ich meine spärlichem ich bin ja ich
werde nicht fit ist gut aber sehr
ungestüm dafür mit auf jeden fall klar
leute ich bleibe trainer soll doch dafür
ist das noch schwach wenig jetzt darf
sein ich geht's eigentlich noch habe ich
auch manchmal hier weiter noch so das ok
eigentlich muss jetzt immer die gleichen
alex mit flexit sind das geschwister
oder so sie sehen sich voll ähnlich wir
haben jetzt eigentlich noch gar nicht
gesagt ob wir das stimmt wirklich
geschwister oder nicht mist einfach mal
raus hauen oder somit nicht machen genau
das jetzt auch drei einfach sagen okay
okay 123 ja bei der hilfe aus offiziell
wir sind deutschlands links youtube ich
dachte dass ich meine sache einfach
nicht weg sagt ich rechne heute okay das
ist jetzt weil die sagen wir sehen
ähnlich aus unterhaltsamen auch alex ist
sehr richtig lustig jetzt musst du und
ich gelacht versöhnlich
alex und ich so bin ich ja selber so
warum
ja ich habe es halt so eingespielt alex
flexit zeit hat läuft und so keine
ahnung haben jetzt drei monate
danke jetzt dass ich wirklich heißt wie
gesagt wir sind brüder freunde
jetzt wisst ihr bescheid ich versuche
sie macht oder zu lesen vorzeitig du
siehst genau aus wie flex leute gibt in
youtube flexity hinaus die brüder riecht
so gut habe ich jetzt auch von mx ste
doch max thieriot raum eine frage ist er
mit paypal oder mit der auch heißt
dieser alex w k wie der geist also der
mit herra chef rief verband hatte ich
mit meiner spieler alex wie auf dem
sattel
hey was ist das denn für uns das war das
licht wieder video von mir gewesen
weißt du warum das so da weil das so
aussieht als wäre ich das
ja es stimmt dass die charlie nicht aus
und es ist ja so schnell angesichts
jedem bild ein blick jetzt mal ein ist
ein bisschen schauen so kam auf jeden
fall machen ja gut das reicht eigentlich
nicht nein das weiß nur so ein kleines
ankündigungs wie wir das jetzt weiter
michael spreng richtig lustig ist ich
habe so etwas noch nie gemacht ja nicht
fand sich dazu überredet dass wir mit zu
machen kann ich ihm und es war lustig so
denn es war hat schon ende märz die lage
hat sich ein bisschen dafür ich zuviel
motorgeräten deutsche das war's mit dem
video zeigt auf jeden fall seinen kanal
ab
dadurch öffnen wie du gemacht jetzt das
aufhören ist ja egal checkt aus freunde
leute ansonsten war's das wir sehen uns
morgen wir genau richtig mit dem neuen
video oder das problem die woche ist
jetzt beendet haben also haben ihren
spaß gehabt alle zuschauer und ich habe
auch heutzutage gut ich weiß aber nicht
wie das filmstudio gemacht hat ich hoffe
da kommt anfang 2000 oder gar nicht so
wenig naja haut rein bis machen
ciao